that's another crazy thing for me with
one piece is like
I don't know what is going on with like
the way women are drawn and now I'm on
Amazon really I'm on the the Amazon Lily
like Arc now so it's like this is the
first time I've seen versatility because
Oda Eider draws women like the most
busted you've ever seen or the just the
same hot uh like super sexy type yeah
yeah definitely and I I you know I want
to talk about too much about uh yeah one
problem I've had is figuring out who is
Nami yeah he's in the manga it's there's
no colors yeah yeah some some frames
it's changing oh yeah like you have to
double take I think he gets better I
think well I can't speak of the manga
but like the the anime definitely starts
getting a little bit better it would
like distinguishing the characters it's
not an anime problem because you can see
the colors you see the color that I was
gonna say yeah you broke there's some
frames you generally have to sit there
for like 20 seconds oh yeah okay you
just gotta you have to figure out like
he he puts different hairstyles yeah but
like slightly sometimes yeah well I say
off to the time skip right it gets a
little bit better so you think I have
not seen it I know this is not there yet
I know how scared you go you're about I
wasn't gonna go in just in case yeah
I know it's gonna happen I thought wow
I'm 500 chapters in it still hasn't
happened okay how the [__] are you in
Japan and like don't get it spoiled all
the time okay no I do but there's so
much [__] there's so much one-piece
stuff it is impossible to piece anything
together okay I go to the gym
[__] watching it all on the
treadmills I don't I I cannot Escape
but there's so much one piece that like
you almost you have no idea when [__] is
gonna happen yeah and because like
weirdest like the art style is so weird
yeah certain characters happen uh have
these Transformations and it means
nothing until I kind of have some
context that's one thing I love about
one piece is that they change outfits a
little bit yeah yeah which I think is so
sick I wish other anime do that yes and
I wish more anime did do that because it
makes them feel more like actual reality
has drip and Hunter Hunter he's always
changing oh yeah everything like
everything
um Takashi draws they they have drips
like you've gone you have a shotgun yeah
very much drip right drip yeah also
bleach bleach bleach bleach I would say
pioneered the anime I think so I think
JoJo is literally permanently stuck on
like catwalk fashion yeah yeah
JoJo's Beyond JoJo takes it a different
level yeah yeah
but like especially like with one piece
even when I started it I got spoiled
with some of One Piece because of like
you'd you'd like go on like social media
you'd see some fan art or someone had uh
Avatar and you go walking in in like
Akihabara and you there's a figure there
yeah
that's what happened to me I bought a
Zorro figure and he doesn't have an eye
I'm like oh [__] like
I'm like come on man
or like I mean I'm sure you've seen like
Luffy with the chest thing like yeah
I've seen I've seen so many so many yeah
goofy looking like Popeye yeah it means
I'm just gonna have to like I the thing
is like it's kind of it's kind of like
Jojo it's like if I tell you like part
seven Jesus Christ isn't it it's like
yeah it gives you [__] nothing yeah
so it's so stupid and so out there that
it doesn't mean much until it's actually
in context yeah yeah I tell you X
character dies that's a spoiler right
yeah yeah you'll agree yeah but if you
see a picture of a character looking
[__] weird yeah you pretty much only
realize that you were spoiled the moment
it happens in the show yeah and at that
point you've already yeah it's already
got to the point yeah it really doesn't
you're just waiting for it to come at
that point right yeah yeah exactly like
I
um for me it was like gear second I I
knew that was coming somewhere in like
the one-piece future yeah
um and I was like I don't know what gear
second is people online keep saying gear
second uh do they get a car or something
I have no [__] clue yeah uh then it
happens and it just like it didn't ruin
it for me because I'm like oh it's so
high this is it and this is [__] this
is why everyone was talking about it
yeah okay I just I just I wish Luffy was
a little less goofy though like that I
don't know I I guess I'm alone in that
tag everyone always yells
I just I wish it was like because like
Zorro's so [__] cool dude I [__]
love Zorro
that's the Samurai Champloo fan and
you've seen that yeah right yeah so but
he is sick he's so funny is my favorite
yeah John's the kind of character that
only works in anime in like real life if
you if someone acted like Zara you'd be
like bro what is wrong with you just
talk yeah well also like even even down
to the sleeping all the time like
no that's like so anime but he's it's
such a sick character yeah even though
apparently what what is the meme people
say he's a racist
well he only fights like black and brown
people he literally no literally and
also and also Oda said that uh he would
be a cop in the real world which is kind
of sad but but whatever like she's still
so sick I've seen compilations
every one of
his enemies are black and brown every
single one
I gotta go back through okay yeah I
gotta go back through it surprisingly
also one piece like definitely the most
diverse anime
uh I will say that if you've gone that
long it'll just happen I think yeah I
think naturally yeah oda's just learned
that like oh diversity is a thing and
it's just like yeah okay yeah I mean I I
think uh you know part of the reason
that I mean I mean Luffy is like
supposed to be Brazilian right yeah
ah I actually don't know I I think
Luffy's his own Enigma
definitely is usop definitely is like I
believe I think he's black yeah he did
say at one point yeah sure I've seen
this on Twitter
they have yeah they have like
nationalities I think and and zoro's
Japanese and and you know Frankie's
American like that sort of thing and I
don't know if that's like added on as
like a style it does make sense though
especially because well you've seen you
you were you finished Water Seven yes
okay so you've seen Frankie yes yeah
okay like he's an arms manufacturer like
he literally is like I need to know that
you didn't even tell me that Frankie was
American yeah yeah I mean he gets
powered by Coke yeah like what the [__]
he'll super like of course yeah that's
like that's like a deliberate choice
he's like he's like a weapons
manufacturer slash like yeah
and is a is a rockabilly which is like
you know very Japanese to like hyper
Focus focus on rockabilly aesthetic I
love that [__] yeah um have you ever
seen any anime or Manga do like
diversity or politics terrible that
you're like oh God no uh was it
okay
where like Simon there's a there's a
black sushi
like that's got to be racist though like
I saw that I was like what the [__]
what are you doing
even though even Japanese people looked
at that was like yo that ain't here what
the [__] did you do that
why you've never seen a black person
yeah it's like you're supposed to be
Russian right yeah yeah yeah whatever
I remember that I remember seeing that I
was like okay that's like that's a bit
much damn that's like in my head it's
like way worse examples yeah
I think yeah dance is probably the one
oh dance yeah but that's only that's
only in the manga that's only in the
market yeah
wait wait what happens I want to know
[Music]
it's so absurd that if I say it I feel
like I must have misremembered it
because there's no way it can be that
bad wait really what the [__] so he
wants to get framed for a shooting right
yes a public shooting because God's is
extremely edgy it's it's it's you know
it's like extremely edgy there's a lot
of violence and Gore and it's great at
some points but this part is definitely
[__] awful yeah it's kind of like a
really [__] up death game uh where
they put a bunch of contestants uh into
a round place in Japan and they have to
kill a bunch of aliens are the aliens
like super Opie and everyone dies all
the time yeah uh so that's kind of like
the series we're talking about I can't
remember why this character does it I
think something is trying to frame
someone who does a public shooting but
so bad and then to disguise himself uh
so that the people that put him as him
he disguises himself as like a black man
and it's so bad it's so bad and the way
they draw it is just terrible
oh that's so bad did like menstrual [__]
it's bad it's so bad oh I gotta I gotta
juice I don't have my phone on me right
now
like I love [__] like that why because
it's fascinating to me yeah it's like
it's like insane that like this guy
thought like this is I found it yeah oh
he's just black face oh that's like
tasteful yeah but that's like a it's a
Japanese dude yeah no no no I understand
I I thought it was gonna be worse it was
so better if it's like I think
what the [__] that one's funny what the
[__] is
um that is yeah that yeah that's the
that's the frame though yeah that's
right it's so bad dude it's pretty bad
that's not as bad as I thought it was
gonna be oh it's just it's just the
notion I thought it was like gonna
disguise myself I thought it was gonna
be straight up menstrual [__] like you
know [__] yeah old depictions like
old-timey depictions yeah Americans
could get way more racist about black
people than Japanese people no I know
yeah something about it an anime that
feels so weird and out of pocket yeah
because it's like whoa there's something
about it that feels uneducated about it
right where it's like they just maybe
media that's why bakkie is the best at
black representation like biscuit all of
us is the goat yeah he's the guy who
runs the prison yeah
yeah very just fundamentally weird
attitude about how American carceral
structure works but is that how it works
yeah yeah you get the the biggest guy
eats everyone else
yeah I mean but I think a lot of it just
comes down to just exposure you know
yeah they don't have the same exposure
this the same conversations yeah all the
same a lot of the same issues you know
that America's going through so it's
just which is why once again odor is the
goat and is like very clearly
anti-racist literally entire slavery Arc
I'm not gonna get too deep into it okay
every anime has a slavery Arc at this
point yeah but like but like this is
very specifically getting into the
details of like how slavery
depersonalizes the the other person and
dehumanizes them in order to
self-justify it and like you see that
and you're like I [__] I see where
you're doing Oda what do you think about
people who are always trying to claim
that anime is inherently non-political
and doesn't even remotely touch on like
you know because people are like it's
it is impossible for us to
uh it is impossible for us to remove
ourselves from politics because like
every facet of our existence is
inherently political whether we
recognize it or not like what you just
described about health care for example
like to you the fact that you have
health care in Japan yeah versus like
Americans not having it like that is a
that is a political aspect of our
existence whether we vote or we don't
vote it doesn't matter it's still
happening so for that reason like
everyone develops their own uh ideas
about the world and how the world should
work or maybe even they have no ideas
about how the world should work at all
and just kind of let things slide in the
way that they currently exist even that
would be inherently political right so
it's just all art is going to have that
subtext it's impossible for it to be
completely removed from that completely
devoid of it and like I said
non-political like being non-political
uh because politics is is ever present
is still a political act inherently so
even that would be a political statement
right you get a law backlash whenever
you talk about these kinds of subjects
where you were like I watch this anime
and this it's about this political idea
I'm exploring this topic
um because I would imagine anime fans
yeah
Community not in my community because
like obviously this is what I do yeah
yeah but having said that I'm very uh
I'm not in the in the same team as like
a lot of people who go oh that's bad
like that's bad politics so you
shouldn't watch that you're a bad guy if
you enjoyed that I don't [__] with that
at all I think that that is completely
devoid of like uh what how you are in
your real life and like the call the
things that we consume do not make us
who we are yeah um and I don't think
that like cultural things have the
capacity to like legitimately shift our
at it it can shift your attitude about
the world it can make you understand
certain things but it's not going to
like all of a sudden make people [__]
extra uh you know evil or extra good or
anything like that yeah
um so I'm not in the I'm usually not in
favor of like you know telling people
like you can't watch that that's bad and
you're a bad person so oftentimes that
is usually when people get mad at me
more is when I tell them like a piece of
content that you shouldn't consume is
not really all that you know it's not
really that game changing like you're
not making a political statement by
telling someone not to watch your thing
like that's just that's not politics
it's just you know you're just
personally stopping someone from
enjoying something